[Musique]
vous êtes passé les relations avec avec
avec votre grand père françois mauriac
gaulliste et jean luc godard gauchistes
jusqu'à jusqu'à 68 ça s'est très bien
passé
c'est à dire que d'abord il y en a eu il
a eu qu'une seule fin de rencontre mais
quand françois mauriac a su que j'avais
une liaison parce que ça s'appelle comme
ça avec jean luc godard et que
j'envisageais le mariage mais sans être
décidée il a eu la curiosité de savoir
qui c'était et il m'a demandé d'aller
sais pas non il n'avait pas vu de films
de lui et on est allés tous les deux à
deux heures d'après vivre à bout de
souffle qui sort d'aulnay dans un petit
cinéma des champs elysées françois
mauriac ce qui est quelque chose dont je
trouve très très énervé yeux c'est à ce
vieil homme qui tout d'un coup à deux
heures de l'après-midi bon tu aimes cet
homme allons voir ce que c'est et il a
trouvé le film monogame
donc il est il était il était assez fier
sur fois que j'ai décoché des cochers
n'ont décroché à 6 ans c'est comme ça
et après donc après 68 les c'est un
petit peu dégradé leur relation c'était
plus dur oui ça c'est ça
ça s'est dégradé de la faute de gens nus
c'est à dire qu'il y en avait un qui
était très tôt coop tolérant c'était
françois mauriac qui acceptaient
complètement fonds soit pointe le
général de gaulle lui-même et un
gaulliste d'autant plus que lui il
allait si vous voulez là le recul et la
sagesse de l'âge c'est à dire il comme
il disait il par donnait les express de
la jeunesse je m'étais pas de guillemets
alors que jean lui qui était vraiment à
ce moment là un fanatique est vraiment
dans le style bon
toute personne qui n'est pas de son avis
toute personne proche général de gaulle
était un fusil et là aussi je mets des
guillemets donc s'il ya eu à ce moment
là une rupture totale et les venues de
la part de l'un qui était très
intolérants et c'était dingue et
jean-luc ils essaient de vous convaincre
de saclay ceux qui étaient proches de
deux vols étaient fusillés au fond du
pont 6 pouces et la fusiller fuzier j'ai
mis des guillemets bien sûr bien sûr
aussi je remets mais il était
[Musique]
terroristes oui et vous au mollement
très mal non c'est à dire vous étiez
d'accord avec vous pour l'année pas au
revoir écoutez franchement les la
lecture de mao tsé toung marx engels
était quand même un talus rentable et
les temps en temps il fallait bien que
je m'y mettre parce que et pourquoi
alors par amour par conscience
professionnelle ou en conscience points
si elle n'est certainement pas par amour
oui ça fait un peu bête mais c'était ça
parce que c'est vrai que c'était pas
c'était pas mes lectures préférées
notre point de vue le meilleur film que
vous ayez fait avec avec jean luc chatel
la chinoise sans hésiter aucune
pourquoi pourquoi pour quelles raisons
d'abord parce que je n'ai pas fait
énormément
eq les facs bonjour je voulais dit one
plus one je pense que c'est un signe
raté quant aux autres non j'ai fait un
passage dans un film que j'aime beaucoup
c'est dans week end il ya un plan très
beau qui est un don qui se passe dans
une cour de ferme ou jégo fait au piano
joue une sonate de mozart traitait de la
chasse et moi je passe avec michel
cournot et ça ce plan est magnifique
dans ce film là mais bon sinon les
autres les filles du groupe bigard
vertov je pense que la période de
jean-luc c'est mon point de vue le signe
à ce que j'aime chez lui ça s'est arrêté
avec week-end et ça a repris avec un
petit peu ce qui peut la vie et
certainement avec passion et que tout ce
qui a entre l'ennui ce que ça s'éteint
il compris ce que ce que je fais et y
compris ceux les autres france des tours
et tout ça ne sont pas des films wade
sont les films qui m'ennuie tout tabou
de choquer et peut-être que justement
comme je ne les ai pas revus
peut-être avec leur tout le ferait le
chemin inverse où est sa magnifique
mais la chinoise a cédé aucun dégât
d'alcool c'était quand même une espèce
de vague de foutaises parce que y avait
jean luc et jean pierre gauran et autour
il y avait trois quatre personnes qui
faisait de la figuration parce qu'il
fallait faire groupe parce que sinon on
aurait dit c'était des films signés par
le couple giga vertov s'arrêter là juste
définition decouflé temps jean luc et
son piano et y avait autour il ya des
mois je serai armand marque aux
opérateurs isabelle pons assistante une
à mingora s'appelait nathalie je crois
plus des disciples et des passagers
c'est ça faisait de la figuration
autour d'un couple lachinois trequesser
c'est non seulement c'est bon ce qu'on a
dit après qu'on leur ait pas en faisant
évidemment un film prémonitoire et
ensuite c'est comme une comité s'est
enlevé comme une comédie de marivaux
c'est profond et enlevés comme du mari
bon ça c'est ça c'est ainsi la revoir
qui est l'un des lieux il ya là par
exemple il ya la grâce de la jeunesse
c'est qu'il a d'un bouddha ou du fil
ce sont vraiment des très très jeunes
gens en face et j'ai cette espèce de
passage après l'enfance et c'est presque
les enfants terribles
les chinoises à revoir je trouve et à
l'époque vous viviez comme ça comme
comme comme des enfants terribles vous
est toujours le moment moi j'ai vécu
j'aime beaucoup de films et le tournage
était très difficile parce que je ne
savais pas bien le où s'arrêtait le
travail et où était la vie privée par
exemple ça se tourner dans un
appartement qui est l appartement je
disais c'est à dire que le matin avant
que l'équipe arrive il fallait à tout
vitesse que je fasse le lit pour que au
cas mon film dans la chambre qui était
le cas d'ailleurs bon il ya une espèce
de mélange de défauts qui avait bon je
me souviens à soi je m'étais disputé
avec jean-luc et le lendemain la scène
était presque vos prises de maux et je
devais la jouer avec jean pierre léaud
et je fais c'était dans un état de
paranoïa temps je me disais mais contre
toute l'équipe doit comprendre que quand
c'est discuté la veille voilà je
n'allais rien à [ __ ] évidemment se
fait dans ma tête
et en plus j'étais très très
terriblement complexé de passer si je
puis dire
après anna karina jett elle s'était déjà
tout va tellement bien tellement
formidable et je me disais je voyais
coûte à genève d'appuyer cet été j'ai
vécu ça de façon très paranoïaque
[Musique]